foreign
[Music]
yes it's a different backdrop but that's
because this is going to be a bit of a
different conversation
[Music]
hello there folks now this
is it's funny I very much debated
whether this was a video that I was
going to put here or over on the Vera
wild Channel I have actually got plans
to start getting new videos up there
soon so go ahead subscribe if you
haven't this would fit a little bit more
into the Wheelhouse over there in terms
of the kinds of things I'm going to be
discussing
but I'm still putting it here because I
want to put this on the biggest platform
I've got on YouTube so
here we go
I need to talk to you about what is
currently going on with the website
only fans
what is only fans
well only fans is a site that allows
creators to offer up their product uh
with a paywall ahead of it so you pay
whatever their monthly rate is and get
access to whatever it is they're
offering sometimes it may be photography
it may be video content it may be
written works it could be pieces of art
it could be really anything
however what only fans has become
primarily known for at this point
is sex workers now I should probably do
some clarifications on that term because
there's an awful lot of people out there
who hear the term sex worker and
immediately think prostitute now while
prostitution is a type of sex work it is
far from the only one and that term
expands to many many Industries
legitimate Industries not that I want to
illegitimize prostitution I will Circle
back onto that issue in a little bit
there's got to be a lot going on in this
video heads up but sex work can and does
include the creation of pornography
whether it be for a pornography Studio
or as an independent Creator it applies
to anyone who works in a strip club it
applies to anyone who releases sexually
based content so it can be said to apply
to people who write erotica draw erotic
art
I'm a sex worker of a Kind I'm a
burlesque performer which isn't
something I I hide I've talked about it
before and while I'll be very quick to
defend the Artistry of burlesque and go
into the nuances and what distinguishes
it from a stripper that's not out of any
sense of superiority because I've seen
some amazing strippers who do stuff I
would kill myself if I tried to do but
it is a different kind of art with a
different platform and often aimed at a
different audience
But ultimately at the end of the day
when I perform burlesque I get on a
stage take off most of my clothes and
get paid for that that is sex work now
that's not to make it seem like I'm only
talking about this because I have a
personal stake in sex work
sex work and sex workers is severely
stigmatized in our society which is part
of what's going on
but we're going to be getting into this
as the whole thing goes on
so circling back to only fans now that
we have a understanding of what sex work
is only fans as I said has become kind
of a central hub for sex workers of
varying types it may be people who are
using it to promote in-person Services
which is not necessarily prostitution
mind you because domination or legal
dungeons are a thing in this Society you
can engage in those kinds of things
where sexual penetration is not actually
part of the scene being played out but
in any case
there's lots of things lots of different
wide variety of creators some of which
don't even appear naked but they still
make content that is appealing to
people's Kinks and fetishes because not
all of those require nudity so it's a
wide spectrum of people and as I said
this is what only fans has become known
for it's actually very sincerely what
the business has been built on it's not
the only thing that is on the site and
it may or may not have been the initial
intent of the site to focus on that but
now at time of recording I believe the
official announcement came a day ago
they come October 1st are going to start
purging sexually explicit content off
the site which has a lot of people angry
I think rightfully so and an awful lot
of people confused because given what
the business is it seems like a very bad
miscalculation because it basically
amounts to we have built up our business
on the back of sex workers and now we're
going to purge them from the system so
we don't have a really detailed
definition from only fans at least that
time of recording as to what they mean
by sexually explicit content they have
said that they will still allow nudity
but that's where things get very iffy
where is the line between nudity and
sexually explicit
there are some things that seem okay
that's a given
showing penetration of a bodily orifice
with a sexual object or body part most
would clarify or classify that as
sexually explicit
but what if it's nudity where that's not
happening but
just the angles the pose is very
sexualized hey there folks it's Vera
from the future or more accurately from
the editing process so I'm going to be
jumping in at a couple of points here to
note some things that have changed or
more information that's come out since I
shot this or to add in a few details
that I should have put it in the first
place the first one is that since I shot
this only fans has put out some detailed
information about what they intend to no
longer allow on their site or at least
what they claim is detailed information
it's actually not nearly as helpful as
you would think though it's more
information than we have before I'm not
going to go through every point at this
but there's two things I want to
highlight the first is that it is going
to condemn both actual and simulations
of the behavior they no longer want on
the site so having an argument of look I
didn't actually do that I just implied
it or I set up a scene that made a clue
that was going on but nothing is
actually shown will not work as an
argument in favor of keeping material on
the site they will remove it simply for
the implication or the simulation of
these things the other thing that I want
to highlight is the term extreme or
offensive which they use in regards to
displays of well the genital area in
general the problem with those is those
are non-specific malleable terms
anything could be deemed extreme or
offensive those are subjective so while
they have quote unquote defined what is
not allowed that definition in and of
itself can easily be moved in terms of
what is considered either extreme or
offensive so again we have more detail
but it's not nearly as helpful as only
fans is trying to paint it now from a
cold logic perspective as I mentioned
this would seem like suicide they're
going to lose not only a massive number
of their biggest money-making creators
on the platform but a whole bunch of
other people are going to leave in solid
Rarity even if they aren't the top
creators and they are going to take
their fan bases with them one of the
things about only fans is unlike say
YouTube or Tick Tock it's not designed
around an algorithm to present you with
creators that they think you'll like
there is that aspect as part of the site
but it's not the major appeal of it
people who do well on the site pull in
interest from other places be it Twitter
Tick Tock although that hmm that one's
dodgy again something I will come back
to in a little bit and things of that
nature or they've had work up on other
sites and they then direct people to
their only fans it's a bit honestly like
how patreon is not designed for people
to just browse and find people to
support so it's not something that you
can easily build as its own platform but
you can direct people who have found
your work or at least enough of a
sampling of your work that they want
more to it that's the case of patreon
it's kind of in the case with only fans
so removing their most productive and
their biggest money making creators or
discouraging them off the platform and
even ones who aren't violating the new
guidelines are probably going to try and
find somewhere else to go because
they're going to worry that they are
going to step on the wrong toe and have
their account nuked then
this is just gonna kill a whole bunch of
the appeal of the thing now
here's one of the things about this
anyone who's been paying attention
knew this was coming we've known for
months that this was coming there were
various signals indicators that made it
very clear that this was coming down the
pipeline there were some people who did
honestly think that it wouldn't happen
because look only fans that's where they
make all their money why would they do
that well
part of the reason and there are others
but part of the reason is that only fans
wishes to pull in more investors
investors tend to be scared off by adult
content so only fans is kind of in a bit
of an awkward position where they have
built themselves up into a company
pulling in over a billion dollars in
Revenue a year and that makes them
appealing to investors but those
investors are scared off by the sexually
based content but removing that content
would remove a bunch of the value of the
business
so when people say this doesn't make a
lot of sense you know you're kinda right
it doesn't the thing to realize is
this isn't really about only fans
this is about the credit card companies
and the pressure being put on them
by puritanical
religious based conservative groups now
I want to be really careful here because
I don't want people to think that I
believe or that I'm saying that anyone
who is a conservative or anyone who is
religious or anyone who believes in a
certain amount of living a puritanical
life to be a better thing I don't
believe that all of those people are
necessarily anti-sex work or anti-sex
some of them and I've known some are
simply in a matter of that is something
I do not wish to engage in at all but
they're content to leave it at that but
ultimately the groups behind what's
going going on and there is one in
particular which we'll get to
they are
puritanical
highly conservative
and religious in their focus and their
goals are to clamp down on every form of
sex work as much as possible and even
the vagus hint of it and many many
companies especially Tech and web-based
companies are scared because if you
think there isn't a connection and there
aren't dots to be connected between
Craigslist
purging its adults listings Tumblr
removing adult material patreon booting
a whole ton of adult contributors and
sex workers who then went to only fans
and now only fans purging it these are
not isolated these are not unrelated
this is all connected this is all by
Design and if you want to get a sense of
how bad it is and how scared many of
these apps are
at the time of recording
about two hours ago actually at the time
I'm recording this my Tick Tock account
which had over a hundred thousand
followers got completely nuked Thanos
gone because I put up a video
making a joke
that at this point there was no way I
would start an only fans account the
point of the video was because of the
current thing going on what we're
talking about right here I'm definitely
not going to start an only fans account
simply because
of the mention of that of that kind of
work
the Bots caught it
and nuked my account
no warning it was just gone now I am
appealing this I'm in the process and
now I know not to even joke about this
which is its own form of [ __ ] so
quick update on The Tick Tock my account
is still gone I appealed the decision to
have it removed and that appeal was
denied I will grant that the response
that I got looked very computer
generated it did not look like a human
being ever actually took a look at any
of this the response does not
specifically lay out what it was that
was the problem and the whole thing just
reads as a form letter unfortunately I
am not aware of any way to get hold of a
live person nor does there appear to be
another way to appeal a second time or
take it to a higher level if someone is
aware of such things I would love to
hear about them but um I have gone ahead
and started a new tick tock account
which I'm doing things on very slowly
because for some strange reason I've
lost my motivation for the platform form
don't know how that happened but that's
the degree of it
someone who has in good standing hundred
thousand followers gone in an instant
because of a reference to a site best
known
for housing sex workers
and my whole account's gone
that is how scared these tech companies
currently are now let's talk about
why let's talk about some of those
groups that I alluded to or really I'm
going to focus on one because there are
others but there's one major one driving
almost everything right now
and that is an organization called
Exodus Cry Exodus Cry
is a group of very well organized
and very aggressive people and do you
remember last year
when PornHub purged basically all of its
amateur creators that was Exodus Cry in
the wake of some content being found on
PornHub that should not have been there
which to be clear is a problem Exodus
Cry jumped on this and created hashtag
traffickinghub and they used the claim
that PornHub was facilitating sex
trafficking which is the common argument
from these groups we'll get to that in a
little bit too
they use that claim to put pressure on
MasterCard and visa to no longer honor
their transactions and they put out a
petition that got millions of signatures
and the result of that was vsan
MasterCard cut off PornHub
PornHub got rid of everyone other than
their verified creators I.E the people
who were willing to provide enough
personal information that PornHub could
track them down and or give their
information to law enforcement if they
ever put anything up that was illegal or
showed illegal activity and purged
everybody else from the system hey it's
me again it's worth noting that despite
this move MasterCard and Visa have yet
to restore purchasing power to Pornhub
and the site is actually been forced to
do all of its transactions through
either direct bank transfer or
cryptocurrency and that's how they're
currently operating PornHub was and is
still the biggest name in the sex
industry especially when it comes to
anything related to Tech and online
content
and they couldn't fight it
they lost
only fans doesn't have a chance so while
from the outside looking in it could
just seem like only fans has forgotten
how it got where it is and is ditching
the people that made it what it
currently is and made it anything of
value they're actually kind of stuck
between a rock and a hard place because
that exact same pressure is not being
applied to them and while visa and
MasterCard have not cut them off they
are deathly afraid of that because
they've had pressure from banking
organizations like Visa like MasterCard
saying we really don't want you to have
this kind of stuff hey folks it's me for
one last addendum MasterCard has replied
to the statements by only fans that say
they are getting pressure to buy
companies like MasterCard and Visa
Mastercard has claimed that they have
not put any direct pressure onto only
fans and while I don't think that's
necessarily untrue it is misleading just
because you're not directly told to
doesn't mean that that implication is
not clearly there MasterCard through its
Behavior towards sites like PornHub and
how just the general wins of finances go
going didn't have to exert direct
pressure onto only fans for that
pressure to exist in the atmosphere
right now so while I believe it is
possible that MasterCard is being
truthful when they say they didn't ask
for this I do think it's very
disingenuous for them to imply that they
have absolutely no part in it because
their current policies are absolutely
driving these decisions now let me be
clear
the source of this is Exodus crying
organizations like it because MasterCard
visa and only fans and PornHub and
patreon Craigslist Tumblr every single
organization that is involved in this
otherwise these are all capitalist
organizations they will do what is best
for their bottom line and if it was just
a matter of we're getting a cut of the
money then none of this would be in
danger because there's money to be made
but the problem is is that Exodus Cry
has enough people genuinely believing in
their mission space statement and enough
people who they have tricked into
supporting them and yes I will say
tricked because I guarantee you the
majority of people who signed that
initial petition against PornHub did not
read the organization's full mission
statement or if they did they didn't
understand it and I'm not trying to call
anyone an idiot but this is not
dissimilar to an organization like
Autism Speaks where the face of it
appears to be something helpful but you
dig into what it actually is you realize
oh crap and when they have looked into
them numerous large names have
disassociated themselves from them after
initially considering in some way
partnering with them this includes
Melissa McCarthy HBO and the
international slavery Museum who once
they realize what these people are
actually about and the fact that their
founder Benjamin nolat condemns gay
marriage and has compared abortion to
the Holocaust cost
they moved away very quickly but most
people don't know that so let's talk
about Exodus cries actual mission
statement and I'm going to read this to
you directly from their site
I will then go into analysis of it but
let's start with their actual words we
fight sex trafficking and all forms of
commercial sexual exploitation
trafficking is one component of a much
larger system of violence exploitation
and gender inequality known as the
commercial sex industry our strategies
are designed to assist and power and
help bring freedom to those who have
been victimized while also fighting to
uproot the larger system of Injustice
and exploitation it made possible now if
you don't think about those words that
can sound okay but there should be a red
flag in that very first sentence and
then an even bigger one in the second
the first sentence we fight sex
trafficking and all forms of commercial
sexual exploitation
that linking of the idea that all forms
of commercial sexual exploitation which
to them is any form of pornography or
adult entertainment
that is synonymous
with sex trafficking or at least they
cannot be separated as far as this
organization and many other
organizations like them are concerned as
far as they are concerned if it is the
sex industry
it involves and supports and benefits
from sex trafficking whether or not they
truly believe that some members do I'm
sure I think some of them know better as
is kind of evidenced by that second
sentence trafficking is one component of
a much larger system of violence
exploitation and gender inequality known
as the commercial sex industry so they
lead with saying that we fight sex
trafficking but then say Oh but this is
just a small part of this much bigger
problem their second sentence makes it
clear their point is not to end sex
trafficking but their point is to go
after sex trafficking as a way to
dismantle all adult entertainment and
everything they consider to be sexually
exploitative and a bit like with only
fans itself as we said earlier how one
chooses to Define that term matters a
lot the specifics matter or not and they
paint it with the broadest possible
brush
if it is in any way sexualized and then
sold for money whether it be buying
industry by an individual they will
label it exploitative so that they can
condemn it with everything else
and let me be clear on a couple of
things here
there is
exploitation within the sex work
industry
there have been and continue to be
issues of sex trafficking within the sex
work industry
however
shutting down sex workers does not help
people who have been trafficked I'm
gonna say that again
going after sex workers is going after
sex workers it's not helping people who
have been trafficked
because here's something to keep in mind
sex trafficking is a crime if you catch
someone who is trafficking another human
being for the purposes of sex regardless
of whether they ever get involved in the
adult industry in any way in shape or
form that is already a crime
especially if they're a minor
criminalizing the work that many adults
engage in Legally or at the very least
demonetizing it and forcing that and
forcing it underground this is part of
the thing forcing it underground first
of all it doesn't make anything go away
the people who are actually in charge of
investigating like at a federal level
said flat out if you remove sites like
this it is going to make it harder for
us to do our job because people on these
sites who engage in legitimate sex work
don't want trafficking either and they
are actually a major resource in
reporting trafficking when it happens
but if you remove
their ability to communicate with each
other
or get their clients all you're doing is
driving the trafficking further
underground and making it harder to
track down an actually stop and let's be
clear about a few other things
prostitution specifically and also the
pornographic industry both have very
long very
horrifying histories of sexual
exploitation and violence but there are
two things that I want you to realize
one about each of these starting with
prostitution the main reason prostitutes
are victimized to the degree that they
are is not inherent with the work they
do it is inherent in the fact that they
cannot go to the police when they are
abused nor can they go to the police if
they see abuse in their industry
because what they do is illegal
nearly everything that is dangerous
about prostitution stems from the very
fact of its illegality which is why
people who support sex workers rights or
just women's rights because that is the
majority of sex workers and this is a
way to clamp down on the very idea that
women have sexuality because if you were
trying to tell me they shouldn't be
selling their bodies how is that any
different from wrestlers from a
bodybuilder from a male Lumberjack using
his physique to do big hard work with
his muscles he is using his body he is
selling his body to someone who will put
his body to use
women have just as much right to do that
as anyone else or at least they should
and the fact that they don't is what
makes this work dangerous and it's
actually incredibly important to point
out that online resources that either do
or used to
facilitate sex workers even prostitutes
in finding their clients made their work
safer they empowered the sex workers to
better be able to vet their clients
before they even found them to not
require pimps which was a huge part of
another huge part of why that work was
so dangerous and again stemming from the
fact that it's illegal they needed
someone to watch out for them back in
the days when prostitution was primarily
done on street corners that was all made
safer by moving it online so then
attacking it online is what makes it
dangerous again
and then in terms of pornography
yes the porn industry has been
horrifically exploitative over the years
but you know what it's done a lot
to cut back on that
giving sex workers the power to work
independently
and that is exactly what sites like only
fans were doing
it was empowering them to not have to go
to an exploitative
casting director
porn studio in order to get work they
could create their own work find their
own Niche build an audience that they
were comfortable with around work they
were comfortable doing
and that is now being taken away from
them
to review
only fans
will be removing quote unquote sexually
explicit content from its site
because of pressure put onto it by
Banking and credit card companies who
are responding to pressure
from organizations like Exodus Cry
who use terms like sex trafficking which
everyone even people involved in the sex
industry all agree is a bad thing but
they use that as a front to Garner
support and go after every form of adult
entertainment and to go after everyone
who makes money that way because they
are puritanical and they will not allow
for the belief that a person especially
a woman of any kind
is empowered to use and sell her body
and her talents as she sees fit in a way
between two consenting adults that does
not affect anyone else and they use that
trafficking
as a way to Garner far more support than
would ever be the case if people
actually knew what they were about
so
what do we do
and I don't have a firm answer on that
because the first issue
is the fact that
the largest
online entity already folded that was
PornHub and now it's only fans
and Exodus Cry and other organizations
like it are just going to keep working
down the line wherever sex workers
migrate to next they will Target that
next in the same way
so if you think well people can just
move their work to just for friends to
many vids to clips for sale and these
other smaller sites that have been
around for a while but are not nearly as
ubiquitous these people will Target that
as well they want it all gone and far
far too much ground has been capitulated
and look you do not have to personally
engage with or even necessarily approve
of sex work
in order to be an ally because this is
harming vulnerable people one of the
recent headlines in the last few months
was about a nurse who made far more
money on only fans than she ever did
from her job this work while not always
being the case but it is possible and
sometimes it does empower people who are
not
getting their due who are not granted
the opportunities or who are
squashed under the capitalist system
to make that system work for them to
offer a service that people are willing
to pay for but because this primarily
benefits women and queer people because
there's an awful lot of them on only
fans and it has anything to do with sex
organizations like Exodus Cry want it
crushed and they are succeeding
the only thing that I know to do right
now
is to educate
and that is ultimately the purpose of
this video
I am trying to educate you and you can
look up everything I've talked about
here I'll put some references in some
cases to this as best as I can so I can
show you my homework on this
but if you look into it truly
look into it you will see that these
organizations don't actually
care just about trafficking they're
using trafficking as a way to shut down
entire legitimate Industries and even
things like prostitution which I would
argue should not even be illegal in the
first place this is hurtful and harmful
to people who have done nothing wrong
because these are activities engaged in
by consenting adults and anytime any
activity is engaged when by someone who
did not consent and or isn't an adult
that guess what that is already a crime
under every laws that we've got on the
books
so that can be prosecuted and targeted
without taking down everything
unless taking down everything is what
you actually want
so that's why this video is here
on the largest channel I have on this
platform
because people need to know they need to
know what these organizations are
actually doing they need to know before
they sign petitions before they donate
money they need to know and then they
can let other people know spreading the
education and spreading the truth of
what is going on and why
right now is the best and possibly only
tool we've got because like so many
far-right organizations
they don't have the raw numbers that
they make it look like
they Garner signatures on petitions from
people who don't understand the full
extent of that business
and they make the most noise possible
they inflate
their numbers in order to outsize their
influence but if we can start
by knowing and being able to recognize
and explain to other people why that is
all wrong
that's step one
then step two is organizing in the other
direction
and helping
people
helping sex workers who have every right
to do what they do
and for businesses to be able to support
them as a sustainable business model
without being forced by credit card
companies who are being pressured to
just drop all of it
none of this was organic none of this is
a truly moral choice on any of the
businesses involved they are having
their hands forced by organizations that
are harmful
and untruthful
I'm going to put links below to some
organizations that support
sex workers and I hope you will check
those out if you want to directly
support what I do
I do not have an only fans
but I do have a patreon
and that is my living
that is how I am supported
and there are probably people out there
simply by the fact that I am visibly
queer would love to be able to pressure
them
to no longer host my content this is a
matter of dominoes
you start by talking sex trafficking you
use it to take down sex work you start
by opening up conversations about
kids who are confused and aren't really
trans or trans athletes in high schools
and you use it as a way to clamp down on
all trans people and you use the
clamdown of trans people as a way to
springboard into clamping down on all
Queer people
these are not single items
this is a list of things that they are
trying to stop whatever your thoughts
are even if you disagree with me drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it simply do so politely
and please remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved
you are the council and I am running
these meetings to the best of my ability
and for the best ends that I can manage
and until next time this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]